this is a production of cornell
university
yeah we'll uh get things started here uh
this is the last episode of our cornell
turf show spring series everybody it's
kind of turning into summer here up
north but
um episode 21 uh thanks everybody for
sticking with us
whether you're live or watching the
recording listening to the podcast
our finale today is going to feature dr
chase straw of texas a m university
uh today chase uh as you may remember
from last year's series
uh chase is delved into the remote
sensing on athletic fields and
we're going to talk about that today
player perception
how they move around around the fields
uh so we're interested for that
conversation of course
uh but as always frank if you want to
kick out kick off our finale
um with uh as always your news and notes
from the past week yeah
i hadn't uh hadn't thought about the
fact that it is in fact a finale hey
chase congratulations you get our this
is our 22nd show uh
since march so we're really glad to have
you here thanks for taking the time and
i understand
you're working with a good upstate new
yorker with a little z curd
oh yeah yeah all right we'll get to that
in a minute
okay so so for now uh welcome to the
show and of course
uh lots of pride down there in texas and
we're all looking forward to
to big full stadiums again everybody
being healthy
vaccinated and moving on with this
situation
uh but for now again just to remind
all of you listening watching uh got
your headphones in
get your hands on what the folks in
maryland did
the mid-atlantic folks did with these
best management practices of course we
talked
about it a couple of weeks ago with andy
um
and and his involvement in that and i
know chase was involved in it as well
so it's just a wonderful publication and
one of the things i noticed is that
there
isn't much devoted to it for collecting
data
on uh various aspects of things like
we're going to talk about now
obviously it's you know it's a volume
one and it's and it was had particular
needs much like our golf one did
and you expect these things to be living
documents uh
but boy this was a monumental
achievement uh for for this industry and
big kudos to everybody
and a big shout out on the last day to
to all the women i know uh in this
business you know i think
it's time we're trying to maybe
normalize some things for people and and
i can't help but thinking that
you know when young women uh see other
women doing this work it's the best way
to
sort of get them seeing imagining
themselves doing network i know for me
it was a big part of
of my career development there were
people i looked at and imagine you know
something that i liked and then i saw
somebody doing it and then imagining
somebody who looked like me doing it now
it's not hard to find you know a white
guy finding what i do but
for those of you women for those of you
like myself with daughters
heather nabasni there in detroit 1999
hired as the first
female grads groundskeeper and and one
of my students uh
at michigan state for the five minutes i
was there amy foughty up at the top
nicole sherry of course one of the
driving forces
uh behind the best management practices
and down at the bottom
i believe this is leah withrow she's out
in nevada and she just
got some acclaim recently she rebuilt
the field out there oversaw the
rebuilding of the field so big shout out
you know all these women in sports turf
management i just think it's great
and and uh i know that they that's a
that these are not easy jobs
no matter what sex or gender you are
this is these are not easy jobs
all right let's talk about the weather
and and really just for those of you
with us with golf you know rather than
sort of rehash some things just get into
the with the dryness that we're
experiencing
uh really the lack of rainfall in the
last week
but the pretty regular rainfall for most
of us through the northeast
particularly in our neck of the woods
here we've been getting a fair amount of
rainfall and of course wherever rich
buckley is there's always guaranteed to
be a little bit of rainfall so
more little rainfall in the metropolitan
area long island a couple of dry spots
in philly
uh looks like further south you get the
drier it gets
and also up in maine now i encourage you
to look at the drought monitor
uh it's not looking good moving forward
so this this is
what seems to be coming warmer weather
dry
immediately carl you know it's in the
90s now
these past couple of days and we're
expecting maybe normal
uh to dry precipitation i mean you know
you know you know how much stock to put
in some of these forecasting things
you try to keep it on your radar but the
trend now seems to be
that we're looking a little dry up here
compared to
uh our our brethren down in the down in
the south now
as we get into this really wonderful
time for growing grass you know i gotta
tell you
i the heat all the heat aside and the
dryness aside
for a period of time there it just
seemed like boy if you didn't have good
grass maybe it was time to find a
another line of work the temperatures
were cool the rainfall was plenty the
nights were still cool
and thankfully we're still getting some
cool nights to help us out for sure uh
but understanding you know how
the grasses are responding to growth um
and then recognizing that you know if
you actually go out there and collected
clippings
like bill kreiser did on this
non-irrigated kentucky bluegrass
uh turf in nebraska in in 2014
um you know you can see that
the growth potential predicted certain
growth and
the actual growth was pretty high early
on in the season
not much in the summer as expected and
then very bi-modal
you can see this surge again in the
latter part of the season now
you look at irrigated tall fescue and
you see something very different
kentucky bluegrass while it you know
seems to support the normal
bimodal cool season growth habit you do
not see that necessarily with irrigated
tall fescue not
a significant growth uh in the early
part of the season
but as a heat build um you can see that
growth was pretty steady and
again growth potential is indicating
lots of growth here on this tall fescue
but they weren't actually seeing it now
this is an important point to keep in
mind
one of the things we're talking about
today is measuring things
you know we're on this we're very data
centric as carl said to me this morning
in our early morning conference call
uh that we're very data centric here at
cornell and when you look at this data
you see well
if i was managing based on growth
potential i'd be thinking it's growing a
lot more than it actually is maybe
there's a way i should pay attention
to the way it's growing now of course
when it comes to mowing in sports fields
i really have always loved this
graphic from some work that trey rogers
group did at michigan state years ago
looking at fertility and mowing height
uh and its effect on uh
traffic and maintaining acceptable turf
cover right and
and it's very clear everybody keeps
saying it we've heard it a number of
times this year
you want grass to grow more fertilizing
it's one thing
but mowing it more also helps mowing
definitely encourages density
and you can see that density translates
to
more uh games simulated soccer games per
week anyway
so theoretically you know by mowing more
you're going to be a little bit more
traffic tolerant
provided you've got the nutrition there
for the plants to do their thing
now let's get into the soil right soil
temperatures now we're starting to move
we're starting to search right all of a
sudden we went from spring to 90 degrees
in four days and the early indications
are that the soils are warming rapidly
and what that means for many people in
places where chemical pesticides are an
issue where you can use them and
if you have chronic problems with soil
borne things like
fairy rings summer patch things like
that maybe on your
kentucky bluegrass you might be doing
fungicide drenches at these times but
one of the topics for today is managing
surface hardness right so
and it that surface hardness in a golf
course
actually is a positive thing and
certainly we know it leads to
uh significantly more um summer patch
sometimes
uh but in general uh you see when you
airfy
you put a little manganese on you get
pretty significant improvements in
turf performance at the surface right so
we know soil management and sports
fields for surface hardness
is going to be important and you're
going to get this added benefit if you
don't have
you know loose sand sand-based
well-drained fields
you're gonna get this important benefit
of not having these root pathogen
problems
but also uh maintaining really good uh
healthy turf with good solid root system
now again of the many things we're gonna
test right of the many things we're
going to talk about today
obviously surface hardness is one of the
things we hang our hat on a little bit
uh but before we get into our
conversation with our guest today
i want to tell you chase we talked to
evan maschetti we had
we had evan on the show uh early on
about five weeks ago
and we were uh this particular article
caught my fancy
where he's taking data you know as a
former groundskeeper now working with
andy
uh he was taking data on where balls get
hit mlb looked at how they got hit
uh the preponderance of these things and
how that might affect
uh surface hardness now recently i think
it's really cool
you know who would pay attention to a
picture like this but a
a major league baseball groundskeeper
this is nicole sherry taking pictures of
camden yards
skinned infield and and boy if this
isn't ever the idealized version of how
a skin should behave
i don't know if i've ever seen one what
a this will be a picture for the
archives honestly
uh that cleat in cleat out with very
little chunking
you know when we talk about playing
surface management for those of you in
the baseball world managing these
surfaces
obviously understanding what your target
is is going to be important now this is
a qualitative
by every measure of qualitative
assessment right you're looking you see
that the cleats going in and out
we're not really taking a piece of data
like evan
is doing here maybe on hardness so uh
the
the ground staff at the maryland soccer
complex uh
really probably in my opinion certainly
puts out some of the most progressive
stuff on
into social media and here's a picture
of some
drone work that they did uh just looking
at remote sensing and
where some of the hot spots that might
not be visible
uh to the naked eye on the field but you
can see here
are quite a bit significant you can see
a few hot spots
around the field and again really
qualitative you're maybe it's ndvi
and you know there's always a scale we
don't know what it means
so looking at this you'd say well you
know i know i got gold mouth and down
the middle issues but i didn't realize
i had that issue in the corners of the
field you know i didn't see the turf
thinning over there necessarily so
they've gone in
and used that imagery uh to improve
maintenance practices they did uh a sand
slit uh drilling
uh practice on these soccer fields they
got acres and acres of them out there
it's a
massive operation uh down there in in
maryland i think it's i think it's
outside of baltimore
um they've also of course drone pictures
of when things are going good they've
done some phrase mowing over the years
uh to improve
the playing surface so very progressive
in their thinking of how they do that
but chase now as you and i start to chat
about these things right you and i live
you know mo both feet in the academic
world most of the time and you
you know as a 70 researcher i know you
spend an enormous amount of time
teaching like richard
white used to do and this is your work
with with uh gerald henry i thought
it's we're i want to talk a little bit
about this as we finish up my intro here
but for sure
the drive down thing is going to be
important for us to talk about today
because
uh you know we're expected to be dry and
you know organized sports are back
in earnest now the other component of
this that you know carl and i talk about
this all the time because we have some
interactions with our
coaches and athletes sometimes on golf
sometimes on soccer sometimes on
football
sometimes on field hockey sometimes on
lacrosse you ask them lots of different
questions i talk to trainers
it's at all ad hoc nothing
nothing actual and and yet you did this
study uh looking at these uh
how athletes perceive these things so i
want to talk a little bit about
athlete's perception and of course you
got some wonderful data here on
on surface hardness and you know
basically heat maps
cold not so bad maybe red uh not so good
and the other thing i want to throw in
the mix today chase is is this
of this idea of synthetic maintenance uh
synthetic turf care
and synthetic turf testing now this is
you know quite a bit more specified in
the astm
lingo than the natural field a bit uh
baselining benchmarking testing is
and you know mcelroy's wrote that review
paper a number of years ago on the
various ways of
testing fields and you know synthetic
turf
as well you know i think oftentimes you
know we put it you know it gets gmax
testing it's getting some testing
but also how do we adapt and adjust to
that testing and how do athletes
uh perceive any differences on synthetic
terms so
the questions further today you know the
tech you know our discussion today
dr shaw uh uh you know include these you
know
what why do we test uh and why do we
test things when we can see them i see
the turf is worn out
you know what do i need to spend money
you know taking all this data
and and okay i see it's variable i got a
native soil field
i i understand it's important but what
am i supposed to do for management you
know i got oh
i got uh i got just a couple of uh i got
just a couple of folks working with me
um how variable if you know is synthetic
turf and then we'll get to the dry
weather
and variability i did you do know this
is the fastest 30 minutes in turf right
chase so
oh yeah we got a lot to go already
taking half of it
yeah that's right that's good so so
let's start with
um what do you say to people when they
say well i got a test for i can see it
well you know that's the most common
question obviously right we have all
this data
especially in sports fields you know
golf
from a management standpoint we can see
a huge reduction in inputs with targeted
management practices
sportster you know you don't see that
big reduction of input so it's all
player safety essentially right i mean
that's why we're doing it
and you know the biggest answer that i
have that question
is is consistency i mean that's our goal
we want a consistent sports build
and you can't put a value on your
eyeballs
you can how green the grass is just
visually but but you can't you don't
have a target you might have a threshold
to guide your management and that's
essentially why you collect data right
if it's surface hardness it could be
ndvi but surface hardness is one you've
talked about a lot
if you're going out and you're measuring
surface hardness if you're communicating
with your coaches and your athletes
and you have an understanding of what
level of hardness
they prefer to fill that then you can
manage your field to meet their
expectations
um you know that's that's why you do it
essentially on a sports field
now if you have a large complex then
that's when the whole precision turf
management aspect
comes in right we have a complex here
locally that has
anywhere from eight full-size grass
soccer fields
six synthetic fields so if you're able
to go out and test those fields
regularly
then you can start identifying how the
different fields
interact between each other and then you
can maybe be a little bit more targeted
with how
your traffic or your use of the fields
uh
or or just specific management um how
much time does it take
i mean you know i don't have enough guy
how much time
10 minutes 10 minutes i mean seriously
that's right
10 minutes on a football field that's
exactly it's intimidating the first time
you do it
you've never done it before just like
anything else but once you've done it
uh you get a system down it's 10 minutes
if you follow the astm standard
very simple less than it's around 10
data points per build
you know so really simple okay so the
key with data
you know carl and i of course we're
we're just loving this this is exactly
the way we think about targets versus
thresholds
and yet we talk about having consistency
and we know there's variability and
you've done this with players
what did you find in your sensitivity
analysis
do they sense when their foot isn't safe
can they
inherently have an idea of their motion
and if it's safe to do will they adjust
how they play
based on some perceived thing that
unless you do this what you're
sort of promoting this intense you know
data collection how
how would you even know how to manage it
so tell me a little bit about
sensitivity and then adjusting your
management accordingly
yeah so so the the study that you
pointed out where we interviewed
athletes was a study that i did in
georgia
right and we interviewed 25 athletes
rugby and soccer athletes primarily
ultimate frisbee
was thrown in there too very unique
individuals ultimate frisbee players
so we took them out to the field that
they all play on the same
field and we ask them take us to your
perceived best and worst
location in the field and then we ask
them how do you perform differently or
do you perform differently when you're
in the field
and so that's where we did the hot spot
maps that you showed here in
the slide and the vast majority i mean
high 80s 90
of people took us to those red blobs or
those blue blobs
either the highest or the lowest surface
hardness for example
and they said that these are the areas
that i i
perceive when i'm playing the game and
mentally it does affect the way that i
perform
um now obviously we couldn't quantify
that in that study but it still was an
eye-opening experience
an eye-opening thing for us that these
these hot spots
matter to the athletes so we should it
basically justifies we should manage
those areas differently
to make them not not an issue right so
in minnesota was when we started
incorporating
the wearable sensors and this is where a
lot this is this is the fun stuff this
is where a lot of uh
a lot of the direction of uh the work
that i'm doing now where we've strapped
some gps
sensors on athletes so we know where
they are in the field we know how fast
they're running
we know accelerations decelerations we
can
see the top speed how fast they're
running
and we've incorporated that data the
speed date speed and distance data
with some of our field measurements and
what we've found
so far with uh rugby players and soccer
players
is when they're in the wettest part of
the field they run slower
which is what we could probably or they
run they run out yeah they run slower
and the wettest part
they went in there they're the highest
in dvi
so the highest turf quality they've run
slower
so you know big big ten country you know
they always mow that
kentucky blue grass really high if
northwestern comes
out or if ohio state's coming to town
with northwestern they kind of create
that mowing height up to slow them down
and you know that's what i think the
the context is there while we're seeing
the data but it's a way that we can
quantify the way that they're performing
now so
these gps devices are becoming really
common they're even trickling down to
the high school they're pretty
affordable
so if you're interacting with a
performance coach or an athletic trainer
that has
that data and you're telling them how
you're managing your field
and they're starting to see trends in
how they're performing then you can
really use that data as well
to manage your field it's so ironic
right carl we just did this with golfers
with the deacon
usga deacon thing we just had carl's
passed out almost 200 sensors recently
for the same thing and you are exactly
right when you say in golf we're using
it to
utilize less resources consistency of
course matters as well
but in your case you're exactly right
it's really it really becomes
about safety and again for those that
think oh my god i got one guy it's like
well
you got one guy you got a two acre
soccer field
uh now you've just described
chase a way i could probably manage if
you look at that paper
maybe a quarter 25
of the field's surface i have to do
something a little bit extra beyond
mowing
you don't have to do it to the whole
surface
how much do you number one do you see
people doing that in your life now
and number two um obviously you want to
go back and test those areas again
talk to those athletes again to see if
what you've done actually remedies the
issue
yeah yeah yeah the biggest i've only
seen people do gold mounts
in soccer uh and then obviously in the
middle of a football field
they'll hit the you know between the
hashes but
we don't know if there's a benefit to
that really and
so i have a graduate student right now
that is taking surface hardness
maps and we are doing site-specific
verification to see if over a long
period of time it'll be a two-year study
are we able to maintain a more uniform
surface with respect to surface hardness
uh as if a blanket approach because i
always give the example if you have a
football field
you know in the middle of the football
field is the hardest part of the field
yeah if you do a blanket
verification you have you have really
hard spots in the middle and the hash
marks
you have soft spots on the wings you do
a blanket verification
you're just decreasing both areas
surface hardness
and then that middle of the field is
going to get trampled so you're
increasing the variability
you do another blanket middle of the
field again over time you're just
you're creating this huge issue in the
middle of the field
huh never actually thought about it that
way but it does make me think about a
nice transition to synthetic turf where
you got rubber
yeah and andy was on a couple of weeks
ago yakking about this and you know he
doesn't like to talk about it he doesn't
like to be told he's like the world
expert
him in soraka but he actually is yeah uh
so so i i actually think it's a good
thing something that you should be
proud of because it's important that we
understand these things so
how about rubber stuff have you done
anything playing around with these
surfaces that indicate they're more or
less variable than a native soil or a
sand
i have not done much comparison between
a grass field and artificial turf but we
have so i actually did a study
i helped write it with john can i share
my screen i'll show it pretty cool right
hey carl you want to give him the host
yeah i think he should be able to let's
see if you can do that chase so we just
published this
earlier this year
i must have missed it um
and what we did was john actually did
all the hard work so this
is this is 12 artificial turf
fields all ranging from so there's field
1 all the way to field 12
and then all ranging in different ages
so we we went from one month old field
all the way to ten year old field
and this top half is surface hardness
and as you can see
it was a really interesting trend that
we found in these shelf fields they were
all in north georgia or south tennessee
they would get harder and more variable
as they got older
which is really interesting and it was a
significant relationship between surface
hardness
and infill depth where as they got older
they would lose infill depth
and become more harder in certain areas
so yeah when you talk about artificial
turf fields
they they aren't maintenance free and if
you don't there's this whole thing of
runaway
rubber right they they get in the shoes
of the kids or they get kicked out to
the side
you know that's i think that's critical
for the longevity of an artificial turf
field is to ensure that that crumb
rubber
is is uniform across the field uh
for the duration of its lifetime in
replacing it so you know you can use
some of these kind of maps to
identify areas where you might be low uh
and then you know replace the rubber in
those areas and hopefully improve the
surface hardness uniformity
so so let me ask you to speculate here
take the work you did where you strapped
you not strapped to gps but you asked
the athletes
to take you to places on the field is it
your
sense that i mean i can tell you i meet
young people teaching classes all the
time chase
and i teach uh sections to different
things about synthetic turf
almost all of them have said they've
never played on natural grass this is
all they've ever played on
is there a sense they can determine the
same variability on these rubber
surfaces you think that they can
on these grass native soil surfaces i
don't think so
unless it's an extreme unless it's a new
field versus a really old field
you know i think it's kind of it's hard
to detect especially the within field
variability aspect
but there's not a lot of research on
that so actually one of my graduates
one of my graduate students right now is
we're moving from the gps sensors on the
back
to uh inertial their inertia measurement
units that go around the ankle
so we can when the athlete's running we
can measure loads that are returned
back so we're taking the whole concept
of the
the hotspot maps that you've shown and
we're setting up agility trials within
the field based on the hardest
and softest areas and having them
perform certain uh
maneuvers within those areas to
determine if they're doing anything
different
within and even between the fields so we
have a grass field and an artificial
surface
yeah yeah and listen we're not going
down the wormhole of footwear
but we all know footwear is a
significant aspect of what
performance is in fact it can overcome
even even
tall grass good footwear good spikes is
probably that's how the packers beat
everybody they used to have
thicker spikes so listen let me wrap up
by asking the last question i had on
there
for for sort of current event stuff and
you did the dry down work
right a lot of native soils right uh
obviously we're experienced we're gonna
expect some dry weather and
and not a lot of you know it's it's not
common to find
heavy use fields that aren't necessarily
a
quality that are irrigated in the
northeast
it's a little bit different down down
south where maybe there are more
irrigated fields because of the length
of the seasons and
for whatever reason um we get into dry
patterns what would you tell people you
know
we were talking earlier about surface
hardness and coring
what about uh hosing should you drag a
hose i mean i've got time for it but
is what did you find when you looked at
dry down that informed
maybe something you tell people as
they're facing dry weather looking
forward
well community level sports builds as
anybody who manages them knows
you know they get hard when they're dry
really hard
so the key is to just maintain cover i
think the biggest thing is to
communicate with whoever's using your
field and make sure that you're able to
spread that traffic out because having
cover there is going to really help with
the hardness and safety of the field i
believe
i'm a huge proponent of wedding agents
and you know maybe that's not
uh a possibility for some places but i
mean they have the tabs you can stick
the wetting agent tabs on the hoses
you know help kind of retain some of
that water in the surface
at all yeah it definitely isn't common
to see a lot of sports field managers
use wedding agents and even andy
andy mcnip made a bold statement a
couple of weeks ago he said i don't
think people should have
i don't think scholastic people should
have sand-based fields
because they don't know how to manage
them they're harder to manage
and the other thing he said was good is
is you know put all your resources and
have one really good feel
right versus taking your resources and
trying to spread them out and having a
bunch of halfway fields
but that does beg to some consistency
differences right you got one really
good game field that you play on
but you're practicing on ooh maybe some
variability
these are really probably intentional
conversations people
these guys need to start having folks
need to start having with their athletes
yep certainly yeah certainly okay
carl it's the witching hour look how
fast that went chase
how about questions uh are there any
questions i i think that one that comes
to mind for me frank is
you know we're doing this work with
golfers tracking their movements and
and we find a big problem between
golfers perception of the putting
surfaces versus
reality what what can they actually
detect sometimes they tell us
and it's really not different sometimes
they don't notice it's a lot
so chase you've done this stuff uh the
perception side of it and now you're
actually tracking them with these
inertial units are you noticing any
disconnect there
um i know i know you mentioned okay they
kind of run slower in
the greener spots and the softer spots
uh what kind of is that variability
limit to what they can actually detect
yeah you know that's a really good
question and we haven't gotten into the
gps data
that in that detail yet but i will say
that
so we did the injury study i think that
you all are familiar with
where we in the same study using the
same athletes where we did the hot spot
maps and interviews
and we tracked injuries over two years
with those athletes
and we found that injuries were
happening happening along the edges or
the transitions
of an athlete moving to high and low
areas
and you know i thought that was really
interesting because whenever we
interviewed the athletes
they always took us to the middle of
those kind of hot spots like the worst
of the worst
but they're and they said some of them
you know the vast majority actually said
that during a game i
probably wouldn't change how i'm how i
how i move in some of these areas
and i think with the psychological
aspect of they wouldn't change how they
move
and they're trying to exert a lot more
energy in these really unsafe areas
that might be while we're seeing the
even though they said that they won't
change that might be why we're seeing
the injuries because they actually do
change or they don't change and they get
hurt because they have like a misstep or
something that's right they get
that they get confused because these the
the reaction times and twitching of
these athletes muscles
is i mean that's why they're high
performance athletes yeah yeah
chase yeah it's so great chatting with
you we could do another 20 minutes but
i wish i would have left a little more
time i tried to set you up a little good
can you
uh carl we got to make sure we get that
link to that nice synthetic turf paper i
missed that one
uh that's definitely something we want
to talk more about
chase i hope you have a wonderful
growing season down there buddy and it
dries out for you
yeah same to you it should it will one
day and then we'll wish for some rain
[Laughter]
well uh thanks uh frank chase of course
for coming on uh
thanks to our live viewers who have been
here most of the way
you guys uh who have come to almost
every episode thanks to you guys thanks
to everybody listening
it's been uh it's been a joy to put this
on for for 10
11 weeks i guess here in the spring uh
frank and i might come back in the
summer we might do a couple
we'll see here there pop up yeah a
little pop-up webinar here and there so
look out for that uh but until then
thank you everybody this has been the
cornell turf show spring series
uh we'll see you all very soon this has
been a production
of cornell university on the web at
cornell.edu